he is David Shaw how are you coach I'm
great rich how are you I am doing fine
are you gonna settle down and watch
tonight's NFL game a little bit if you
get a chance I know you got a big game
coming them a couple weeks you know yeah
a night we get out of the office I get
the coaches out of the office we don't
have dinner here which we call a family
dinner night so we get out get out and
get away so okay
our our kids are really excited of
course to watch there's two tight ends
so it's a Stanford tight end on one side
of Stanford tight end on the other side
so we're gonna kick back and watch the
game okay so you got water you got urged
it's the Ertz Hooper our is that what it
is absolutely absolutely
you know everything's local I love it
before we start our conversation about
your team college football etc I do want
to revisit some of the stuff we talked
about on the NFL Network last April are
you surprised that Sam darn 'old is the
only starter from that rookie
quarterback class that we saw drafted
that night in Dallas yeah absolutely not
absolutely not um I saw this kid it was
especially the last two years that quick
release the quick decision-making the
great seat the the anticipation which is
I put on par with anybody that's come
out of college in the last ten years his
anticipation of throws and seeing
windows it's impressive
so it didn't surprise me one bit so you
think he will transit transition into
the NFL smoothly how do you how do you
see it going for him in the Jets then oh
he'll he'll have some dips here and
there which they all do that he'll have
some rookie moments but this guy's gonna
have some flashes because this is how
he's built I think it's not long before
he's in that top you know a third of
quarterbacks in the NFL and then maybe
even higher after that and then Lamar
Jackson in in Baltimore he is being he's
listed as the second quarterback but
word is in your old stomping grounds
professionally that it's gonna be RG
three who would trot into the field to
back up Joe Flacco what do you think his
transition knowing that organization as
well as you do is going to be there in
Baltimore well I think it's the
phrases roster management whereas our g3
is probably the next best quarterback to
go in and play quarterback but they're
gonna have a role for this guy they've
got multiple guys on staff that know how
to get the most out of an athletic
quarterback like this that can throw
there's no it's not this is not a
receiver running back they're putting
out that quarterback this kid can throw
and he can throw deep and you get
through accurately but as they're kind
of spoon feeding them a little bit let
them throw dip in the water they're
gonna find a way to help this for this
guy to help them win football games so
what that means but I know we talked
about this briefly cuz it happened and
the last pick of the night you know we
get off the air so quickly but I mean
how aren't you if you think he is your
quarterback of your future I mean don't
you run the risk of getting them what
are you gonna put them in the slot
you're gonna put them next to Flacco I
mean how do you how do you work that you
know and that's why I say roster
management because if something happens
to to Flacco I'm just guessing I'm not
there so I'm guessing they're saying hey
you know he's not ready to be the down
up to down player on a team that wants
to win the Super Bowl
this is not a rebuilding franchise this
is not where the Jets are where hey
we're gonna have some bumps but this
guy's going to grow this team wants to
win right now and they're built to win
right now that defense is impressive
they've got weapons so so Robert
probably gives them the best chance if
something happens to Flacco but to be
able to put especially a third down
package together be able to put a red
zone package together for this young
superstar to come in there and affect
the game as a runner and as a passer
that may be too inviting not to have
which is why you carry three
quarterbacks which most people don't do
nowadays but if you're not sure that
that superstar is ready to play an
entire game you got to have a backup
quarterback who's in-house and ready to
go something happens the middle game and
I don't know if you were able to speak
David Shaw at any preseason action
involving the number one overall pick
that night Baker Mayfield I know you're
concerned about height on draft night
and that's the reason why guys that tall
Oh aren't drafted first overall very
often if ever in the NFL any of those
concerns alleviated so far from you know
not not at all but once again for me
there are anomalies right drew Brees
an anomaly there are a lot of guys with
drew brees dimensions that were
outstanding in college that are watching
NFL football or not playing NFL football
which is what the thing when you watch
Baker Mayfield and I'm one of those guys
I like to prototypical 6-2 and up
quarterback when he watch the kid play
all those things I described to him
Donald this kid's got the same thing
quick release he's great in the pocket
he's not good in the pocket he's great
in the pocket he can find windows he can
peek around i'ma see if he's got time to
throw it or needs to escape he's got all
those things and on top of the
intangibles you just wonder at time oh
gosh it this is a guy's wide open the
ball gets bedded down or guys wide open
can he not see but if overtime he's
proven to be that next Drew Brees type
of a quarterback which I don't want to
put him in the running quarterback
category because this kids a quarterback
he can play from the pocket and if he
can see like Drew Brees can see this
kids got chance to be really good
David's just just over time you get a
fee David Shaw Stanford head coach here
on the Rich Eisen show let's talk about
luck a little bit here I my eyes are
wide open from some of the stories we're
hearing about luck his quotes calling
him during his process of dealing with
his shoulder injury called himself ace
at the time what he was a sad miserable
human scared about football and a
miserable sob to be around did you sense
that when you were in any contact with
him over the last year plus David we had
we had multiple conversations at
different periods at different times and
as I tell all these guys I want to be
here for them no matter what but things
are great when things aren't great when
you're playing the Minnesota when you
get out of the NFL and you're going into
whatever business you do after the NFL
and so we talked to some about football
we talked some about life a little bit
it was great to have him back here on
campus on the offseason and
he had to work through a lot and you're
look you're talking about a man now
that has never really had to struggle
he's brilliant he's athletic he's got
all the intangibles and all the
tangibles that you're looking for to
play the game and he went through
something traumatic um where he he
couldn't play he couldn't go out and do
what he loves to do and what you've got
now is a healthy guy that appreciates
going through the depths of what he went
through and now back to out there being
healthy and he's still not where he was
before but I think between the ears he's
excited he's energized he really loved
you've heard him say it too he now he
knows he truly loves the game he
couldn't wait to get back and play and I
think he still may have some rusty
moments early in the year but I would I
would guess by midseason if he gets him
to true and you look for him with the
guys that they've got around him and the
offensive line now that they rebuilt in
front of him he's got a chance to be fun
in Indianapolis yeah that was another
thing that caught me by a little bit of
surprise is that he learned he loved the
game I mean is it possible that guys
don't realize of such an ascendancy of
his or in general that I don't know the
game until they lose it you know
absolutely it is you know I coached in
the NFL for nine years there are some
guys that are so good at it and it comes
to a natural but obviously even the ones
that don't do it on purpose sometimes
they take it for granted hey I just show
up and I go dominate and I go home and
then I go to the mall and I go to movies
and hang out I come back to practice and
I dominate again that's just how they're
built until you get to that point where
it's not easy a lot of them happen when
they get older and they oh my gosh I
have to work harder now I don't want to
leave this game I love this game I got
to work hard and out up to prolong my
career and some guys like Andrew even
wonder kind of young and they go through
an injury they go through something I
said that the way it looks like the game
either physically is going to be taken
away from it but not going to be able to
do it at that level anymore and it hits
him like you know I wasn't just coasting
there I think I actually enjoyed this I
missed
I'd love this and then you get renewed
and to see Andrew walking around by the
time he left here to go back to
Indianapolis walking around on his toes
and I can't wait to get back can't wait
to get back in the huddle can't wait to
get back my line my guys and deal with
my guys so I'm excited for and then last
one for you on the professional football
front here coach
it appears in Carolina Christian
McCaffrey is gonna get a healthy dose
like 300 plus touches type dose like
Maine bell cow type dose what do you
tell Panther friends about Panther fans
about his readiness for such a workload
do you think ya just stay on the edge of
your seat stay on the edge of your seat
this young man at Chris and I talked a
couple times this summer and he is he
has worked so hard to get to where he is
and he's worked so hard this offseason
because you don't know what the NFL is
like until you go through a year right
so he thought he was prepared last year
and he was prepared to do well over 80
catches and played really well but now
he knows the demands on his body and I
think he's stronger he's worked on this
a lot of things I think he loves the
offense and the way the direction the
office was going with a North Turner
he's fired up and he's physically and
mentally and emotionally ready to go and
I think he's gonna he's gonna surprise
even people that liked it last year I
think he's gonna be even better this
year like between the tackles Nora's
gonna use them between the tackles do
you think hey this kids a football
player and even though over the in them
and the preseason I think you get a 80
yard run or 70 something yard run it was
between the tackles and for all Stanford
fans we saw that happening today we've
seen that a bunch here alright so let's
talk about your current team the one
that you're sending out on the field
against USC this weekend where do you
where do you stand on I'm playing such
an important crucial game so early on
and obviously you know every single
college coach I've had on over the past
few weeks and I've talked about this
with you to you there's no training camp
there's no scrimmaging against other
programs I mean you just come right out
of the box and have to compete where do
you stand on having such an important
game week to coach well I think we would
all prefer that this thing was pushed
back a week or two maybe week three week
four but at the same time there's a
reason why a lot of people play those
preseason matchups you see Washington
Auburn you see LSU their game the other
night you see these exciting games early
on so on that side of it I don't mind
because so many of these games are out
of conference games everybody wants a
tune-up game and now to play week two
two teams that there's a reason why it's
also not that way tonight because it
gets a lot of viewership on the East
Coast
these have been some of the more
exciting games of the year year after
year you're gonna see a lot of guys that
are going to be household name some guys
at our house will name some games are
household names after this game because
these games are physical they're
exciting and they many of them go down
to the wire well you got a Heisman
Trophy candidate at running back and USC
gave up over 300 rushing yards last week
against UNLV you think that's uh
something to exploit this coming weekend
sir of course you know I'm teasing Bryce
is a special special football player and
we could go we didn't get a chance to
run the ball very much or very well
against a team that was dedicated to
stopping them where we put the ball in
the air and kg castello threw for over
300 taters take a wide side had a had a
monster game as well but the clay Helton
knows we're going to come in we got to
run the ball we want to establish the
run we'll use the play-action pass we're
going to do the things that we've done
they have a very similar philosophy
they've got a superstar quarterback
that's just starting his career and some
really good talented receivers they went
establish the run also this has tends to
be one heck of a football game all right
I'm glad when you mentioned other
contests from this past week and you did
not mention my alma mater versus Notre
Dame although you know I mean it's just
week one you never know long-term season
what did you do did you catch any of
that game knowing that you got Notre
Dame later on I know that you had your
own game but if you are you already on
to something like that at all coach oh
yeah another has a new defensive
coordinator so I was able to by the time
I got home after doing some family stuff
I was able to actually see kind of the
second half of that game I want to see
what nobody em was doing defensively and
I know I know Wolverine fans are a
little little anxious right now but
they've got a young team they've got
some guys in some positions that two
weeks three weeks are now going to be
really really good so I'd stay tuned I
think those were two really good
football teams and in my it might be a
little early for Michigan a place that's
against such a good team right now but
these guys have a chance to learn and
grow they're still learning and growing
with their quarterback
and put them in the system who's got a
chance say Patterson's got a chance to
be really good quarterback as well so
I'd stay tuned with that team also okay
coach
really appreciate the time always enjoy
our chats always do
thanks I'll talk to you always right
back at you we'll chat down the line
that's David Shaw off Stanford at coach
David Shaw the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience